why do you hate Fridays so much because
I hate people that live their lives for
the weekend I'm blown away by people
celebrating the end of the week
like the weekend is your escape from
your reality it breaks my heart my
friends like live for Friday night like
they know they get there wait like
Monday mornings the worst to live your
life where you love Friday night
Saturday and Sunday and despise Monday
through Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life like 50% of your
entire life is predicated on what you do
it were like it's just a huge percentage
of one's life and I'm trying to put
pressure on the conversation to say if
you love Friday that much then you need
to really look at Monday through
Thursday and see if you can do something
about it Sunday night I'm like chomping
I'm like a fighter before a fight like
in the dressing room like I can't like I
try to go to sleep early on Sunday
because I can't wait for Monday cuz I
got to put my jersey this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the Internet
you can make [ __ ] happen you can build
businesses or side hustles take less
money and like live a little more humbly
to set up your next 50 years so many of
you are so hungry for short-term
short-term gains like maximizing the job
that paid you $3,000 more but it's not
as fun but you want that $3,000 for what
for what for a new iPhone for what I get
to live life one time I'm talking about
if you genuinely dislike what you do so
much that you beg for fries listen I
lived 12 years of this and definitely at
least nine I just don't understand why
people relegate into losing mentality
just thinking they can you can't because
you want to be on the bowling team or
softball and play video games that's why
you can there's plenty of time gets [ __ ]
done
the thought that that is so many
people's work lives which will be the
disproportionate percentage of how they
live their lives breaks my heart if I
can get one person to be like Lucky's
right like what the hell am I doing here
please do not waste the next 5 10 15 20
30 years of your life and allocate 30 40
50 60 percent of your time to something
that you here can end each and every
week if you genuinely celebrate Friday
you need to rethink your entire [ __ ]
game
[Music]